hello everyone and welcome to today's
five broadcasts a new paradigm for
brunelfran testing presented by dr. judy
stone senior technical specialist
University of California San Diego
health center for advanced laboratory
medicine mass spectrometry toxicology
laboratory I'm Alexis Krause of lab
verts and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar has brought to you by laborat
and is made possible by an open
educational grant from Agilent Agilent
has had no input in the selection of
speakers content or mode of presentation
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button well
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
answer question box located on the far
left your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits
I'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr. Judy stone dr. Judy stone worked as
a clinical laboratory scientist in San
Jose California and then obtained her
doctorate in clinical biochemistry at
the University of Toronto her fellowship
in clinical chemistry was at the
University of Minnesota Hospital and
Clinics
she has since served as assistant
professor and associate director of
clinical chemistry at the University of
Connecticut Health Center as assistant
professor and director of the core
immunology in toxicology laboratories at
the University of Massachusetts Medical
Center I've worked with mass
spectrometry at specialty laboratory San
Francisco General Hospital in Keizer
regional laboratories in Northern
California
she is currently senior technical
specialist in the clinical mass
spectrometry laboratory center for
advanced laboratory medicine University
of California San Diego Health System
her research interests are in mass
spectrometry method development
validation and automation for clinical
toxicology and endocrinology she has the
faculty chair for the new 2009 edition
of the AACC online certificate program
using mass spectrometry in the clinical
laboratory
she teaches with a team of colleagues a
two-day short course on getting started
with quantitative Elsi tandem ms in the
diagnostic laboratory ms ACL meetings in
the US and europe she is a member of a
acc and a SMS and serves as chair board
of editors for the mass spectrometry
feature series clinical laboratory news
dr. stone you may now begin your
presentation
Thank You Alexis for that introduction
and I'd like to start out by also
thanking lab roots and Agilent for the
opportunity to speak to do today about
some of the work we've been doing with
buprenorphine testing at UC San Diego
I have to start also by thanking my
collaborator is dr. Rob Fitzgerald's is
the director of the toxicology and mass
spectrometry laboratory here at UC San
Diego chiefly dr. Emmerdale Pesta is the
director of precision toxicology who
first got us interested in testing for
naloxone
I guess at our CEO who is our liaison
with tea can for the collaborations that
we've done with them using the AC plate
Judi Tang my colleague from Kaiser who
generously shared some de-identified
specimens and results with us for
comparative testing and finally Heather
tone Josh akin and Don Francisco my
colleagues here at the UC San Diego lab
who helped with the validation of the
methods I'll be talking about as well as
most of the production testing that I'll
be describing so broken the presentation
up in just reports today first of all
why are we interested in buprenorphine
at all when we're talking about testing
with LC tandem mass spectrometry in a
clinical laboratory next we need to
discuss some some buprenorphine
pharmacokinetics and in understanding
how to interpret the urine test results
so that we know what's appropriate for
designing methods and how to report them
and finally the meet if you like of the
presentation which is the analytical
chemistry for testing a free
buprenorphine and metabolites at sub
nanogram per ml cutoff using
LC tandem mass spec so why do preneur
fame
you don't need to be a clinical chemist
or toxicologist to know you just need to
read the newspaper every day that we
have an opioid abuse epidemic and the
United States as well as in other
countries typically called opioid use
disorder and opioid agonist therapy is
one of the most effective names for
treating that so what is opioid agnus
therapy it's chronic administration of a
long-acting slow onset opioid in the
United States that would be methadone or
buprenorphine and the reason that this
therapy is effective is that it relieves
the withdrawal and craving that people
who are abusing short-acting opiates
like heroin or oxycodone or other or
fentanyl experienced most of the time
there's only when people are using those
types of the drugs really a smaller
amount of the time there's actually the
rush or euphoria immediately after a
dose and you don't get that with a
long-acting slow onset opioid like
methadone or buprenorphine
so using this medication improves
retention of patients and a treatment
program reduces the risk of infectious
disease from injecting drugs and
criminal behavior in order to obtain
drugs illicitly so it's really the most
effective treatment for opioid use
disorder there's a lot of studies to
prove that I've given you a couple of
references there at the bottom and
usually it's combined with behavioral
therapies and other types of
psychosocial support so methadone has
been available for a long time
buprenorphine really since the 1990s
routinely used at first it was thought
that buprenorphine was not as effective
as methadone in treating opioid use
disorder but more recent studies and
particularly when there is an
appropriately high dose I have shown
that they have similar efficacy and
again I have some references for you at
the bottom of the screen buprenorphine
does cost more than methadone for the
medication itself but I was interested
to see a recent study that's the second
reference down at the bottom of the page
that if you look at the total cost of
treating a patient that they may be
similar for buprenorphine versus
methadone obviously that depends on the
setting in which care is delivered and
how those cause are assessed but I
thought that that was an interesting
finding so what is the advantages to
using buprenorphine in the u.s. in
contrast to methadone is that they're
what I've called easier regulatory
access what do I mean by that well
buprenorphine can be dispensed at a
physician's office rather than having to
have treatment at a methadone clinic so
if you had say a community that needed
to be offering treatment for opioid use
disorder it would be much a more
regulatory burden and much more
expensive to have to open a methadone
clinic
whereas existing physician offices could
provide treatment with buprenorphine
there's less stigma for people who could
be going to the doctor's office for
antihypertensive medication or for
buprenorphine or as if they're going to
a methadone clinic that's a little more
specific as to why they're there
but our problem is that we have too few
doctors at least in the United States
who are trained and certified to use
buprenorphine and there's insufficient
funds for treatment so even though there
should be access should be easier in
fact we do have logistical barriers and
so we have insufficient number of
patients being treated so buprenorphine
can be is available with a prescription
by itself or formulated with naloxone
buprenorphine is a partial opioid
agonist it has relatively low sublingual
bioavailability but it has very low oral
bioavailability so that's why it's given
either as a tablet or as a film as shown
there in the photo because the
sublingual bioavailable below about 35%
is certainly better than the oral
bioavailability and there is a new
formulation just recently out called
dub solve where the bioavailability has
been increased to about 45%
so the locks down again as anybody
reading the newspaper knows is an opioid
antagonist so how can that be useful if
we're trying to Detroit with an opioid
agonist or partial agonist well naloxone
is given under the tongue
sublingual a really has extremely low
bioavailability 2% or less in most
studies and so essentially insufficient
active drug gets delivered systemically
in order for it to act as an antagonist
so the typical mixture would be a four
to one ratio of buprenorphine to the
lock zone and a sublingual film or
tablet but if that is used parentally
meaning if it's injected or snorted it
may indeed cause withdrawal at some if
but also not all users and that's
because I'm showing you their public
health announcement about the dangers of
snorting suboxone one of the mixtures of
buprenorphine and naloxone that's
available because naloxone has much
higher bioavailability if it's taken
nasally so how is this supposed to work
just showing you here in a diagram the
idea would be that if the medication is
taken as intended for therapeutic use
sublingually both the buprenorphine and
the naloxone dissolve out of the film or
tablet but the naloxone essentially
isn't delivered systemically because of
the low bioavailability whereas the
buprenorphine has sufficient systemic
bioavailability to circulate they become
bound to opioid receptors and to deliver
the desired therapeutic effect however
if the tablet or film is crushed up or
dissolved in some manner so it can be
injected or started then there's much
higher availability of the naloxone and
so systemically it can bind to opioid
recessed receptors and block a potential
buprenorphine effect that one might
obtain from injection that is the
euphoric high that would be desired
so the idea behind if you for northing
naloxone formulation is that it's going
to deter diversion so just to reiterate
the sublingual use is effective for
opioid agonist therapy because we have
predominantly a buprenorphine effect
whereas an insulated or injected mixture
of beef an orphan and naloxone would
have primarily in blacks own effect that
is antagonistic it can elicit withdrawal
and can prevent or minimize the euphoric
high in a subset of circumstances so the
naloxone effect predominate there are
some limitations then locks on half-life
is much shorter than that of
buprenorphine so that effect the
antagonist effect can wear off well the
buprenorphine is still around that ratio
of one to four may not be sufficient in
all circumstances to block the
buprenorphine agonist effect and finally
the antagonist effect that is inducing
withdrawal is somewhat dependent on what
the status of the patient's opioid
receptors were at the time that the
Intag the antagonists of naloxone is
administered so if a patient was taking
a light dose of heroin or oxycodone
let's say they might go into withdrawal
if they'd been taking buprenorphine
chronically at a high dose it would have
less of effect so the bottom line is in
public health study is that it is
effective to deter diffusion a diversion
sorry it's just not perfect so we we are
talking about laboratory testing how is
that useful in the setting of
buprenorphine administered to treat
opioid use disorder
I like this statement from the US Samsa
advisory sublingual and trans mucosal
buprenorphine for opioid dis disorder
and they're reminding us that laboratory
testing is only a tool and it shouldn't
be relied on exclusively for clinical
decision-making I think often those of
us in the laboratory place too much
emphasis on the actions that are going
to be taken from urine toxicology so
it's good to remember that it's used in
context
and as well it's good for us to continue
to inform clinicians when we act
interact with them on the limitations of
urine toxicology because you're in
concentrations can vary with the
patient's hydration status is it
concentrated or dilute of course if they
have impaired renal function that's
going to affect the ability to
concentrate urine and chiefly when we're
talking about super northing the
interval between the last dose in the
specimen collection time that's always
of interest but in this context the
ratios of buprenorphine to metabolites
and to naloxone are variable depending
on if you take the urine sample an hour
after the dose or 24 hours after the
dose and so that's important to consider
another reason that testing could be
helpful is around the issue of
adulteration of urine sample with the
before buprenorphine naloxone film or
tablet so the goal of course is to try
to mimic compliance of a patient has not
been taking their dose or if they'd
diverted some of it so that our imminent
to a friend and so this is a quote from
a reference that I have there at the
bottom of the page that I would
encourage anyone who has to interpret
results to read I think it's very useful
and well-written because even though
only a small number of patients were
identified to have Spice their urine
samples quantitative testing may help to
identify urine spiking during office
based opioid treatment with
buprenorphine so let's go on now and
move to part two talking about
metabolism and pharmacokinetics so that
we can understand some of these
statements about interpreting the urine
drug results let's start with the
structure so there's the structure of
buprenorphine it's somewhat higher
molecular weight and many of the other
opioids that we test for around 467 it
has it's a synthetic you can see that it
has the basic basic
Morphin and ring structure that I'm
showing you there in turquoise and when
buprenorphine is metabolized it's MD
alkylated 2 nor buprenorphine so you can
see where that group is removed there's
the structure for naloxone at 327 a
molecular weight much more similar to
many of the other opioids that we test
for and all three of these compounds
our have a Gujarati group added at the
free position as part of their hepatic
metabolism and that's an interest both
in terms of how the drug is handled in
the body as well as what we do with it
analytically in a urine sample the next
thing that I want to mention is looking
at some of the form of the code kinetic
parameters from sublingual
administration studies this particular
numbers that I'm showing you here comes
from the FDA approves the book suboxone
medication guides and you can see that
milazzo is listed as having elimination
half-life of about six hours that's
actually the longest that I've seen if
you look at other studies it's as short
as one to three hours and you can see
that noir buprenorphine has the longest
elimination time almost ten times longer
45 hours and that's the one that I've
seen the most variability for sometimes
extended out to cemani or even 100 hours
and buprenorphine is is slightly shorter
so as I mentioned earlier naloxone has a
much shorter half-life than the other
two compounds if we're looking at
metabolism and the issues of laboratory
quantification obviously we're going to
be measuring some of the parent drugs
but it turns out that it's really not
the most predominant species so as I
mentioned it's metabolized to nor
buprenorphine as well as to
buprenorphine glue Quran ID and nor
buprenorphine is metabolized tune or
buprenorphine blue karana naloxone is
also MD alkylated to normal axons but we
won't be mentioning that in a further
most of the metabolites that we'll be
talking about is naloxone blue kieran
eyes so these are of interest
analytically because you'll hear or
you'll see in our report that we talked
about total naloxone or total
buprenorphine and what we mean by that
is that the free components that is the
buprenorphine
nor do pornography and naloxone are
relatively easily to analyze but we need
to cleave off the glitter on eyes from
the glue Toronto and metabolites to make
them easier to analyze so we do that
typically with an enzyme
using I draw
this protocol during sample preparation
and then we're converting those former
glutes around eyes back to the free drug
so and we're measuring total it's the
free plus the goop you're on eyes that
are now also free drugs we have one
process for measuring both species if we
look at the relative concentrations in
urine and this is data from our work
here at UCSD so it's with sublingual
dosing just of patients who are in
treatment nor buprenorphine gujrat ID is
the most abundant species in urine now I
should point out that we don't measure
the glue tyranide itself we measure as I
just described total Noah buprenorphine
and free and then the difference between
those two should be the glue tyranide
now I've listed naloxone glucuronidase
the second most abundant species but in
fact in many samples we see the
concentrations or is high if not higher
again this is for total minus the free
as nor buprenorphine glue to remind the
pukin or can glue cyanide itself is
actually a lower concentration and
lowest of all are the free
concentrations free buprenorphine higher
than buprenorphine itself and free
naloxone the lowest concentration now I
can see anybody who's familiar with this
testing or even if you just listen
closely to what I've been saying saying
what do you mean that you have naloxone
and naloxone bromide present in urine
what about what you just told us that
buprenorphine has this very low
sublingual bioavailability how are those
two statements how can you say that both
of those things are true so when I
showed my boss this data this was his
comment that was like recent headlines
of fake news or alternative facts how
could it be believable when all these
years we assumed that there was no
absorption of naloxone from a sublingual
film
so when we first developed our methods
and we were measuring only total not
free drugs we expected that in this
cohort of 69 samples that some from our
institution that had been measured at a
reference laboratory and some from other
laboratories that had shared specimens
with us
that all of the naloxone that we
measured would be quite low less than a
cut-off of 10 we actually were able to
achieve ultimately a cut-off of five
nanograms per mil so that's what we
expected but this is what we actually
observed which is only a few specimens
with concentrations below the detection
limit and most of them with relatively
high concentrations indeed you can see
that the most commonly encountered
concentration was between a hundred and
a thousand so what could be going on
well dr. Peston from precision
toxicology had been generous enough to
share 20 samples with us and he had also
described this phenomenon so we thought
let's take his samples out of the mix
and see if that was biasing what we saw
but again we saw the same thing so with
only 49 samples we saw a median value
for total naloxone of two hundred and
forty five milligrams per mil 49 is in a
very big cohort so again dr. passe was
generous enough to share his data with
us for a much larger cohort of 44,000
samples and they've seen exactly the
same thing and their median value for
total naloxone was 363 nanograms per mil
so what do we think is going on why is
it that most people would say you would
not detect any naloxone in urine and you
have sublingual buprenorphine naloxone
administration why are we seeing so much
well of course my possibility could be
analytical error we had a reasonable
correlation between our concentrations
and those at precision toxicology and
since then we've compared with a couple
reference labs and again have reasonable
agreement within 20 or 30 percent so for
the moment we're going to rule out
analytical error
now you could say that perhaps sample
adulteration is more common than you
think but we actually ruled that out
fairly quickly because as I'll show you
shortly
the relative concentrations of free in
total in the lox own buprenorphine and
nor buprenorphine and adulterated sample
are quite different from those in a
compliant sample so it could be that
really we have the wrong expectations
for how this drug is being used for most
patients that is perhaps it's the norm
that almost everybody is taking the
medication sublingually also does some
injection or snorts part of their dose
and that therefore they have higher
naloxone concentrations because remember
both of those ways to administer the
drug does deliver higher naloxone we
don't really have any way of ruling that
out with the information that we have
but we think instead that we have to at
least consider that what it is is that
we have the wrong expectations for what
I called B and access the joint
buprenorphine naloxone preparation for
those pharmacokinetics so let me show
you that graphically to here I'm
representing someone taking their
sublingual dose of course this
buprenorphine there but we're just going
to focus on the naloxone
and that pink bar that I've labeled this
tissue is just really the mucosal layer
across which absorption
has to occur and so our expectation is
always that we had no absorption of
naloxone but really when we talk about
bioavailability and pharmacokinetics
studies we're not just talking about
absorption we're talking about
metabolism so we're postulating the one
maybe happening is we do have minimal
absorption of naloxone
but then relatively rapidly it's
circulating systemically it goes through
the liver and most of it is gluten Rana
dated but if we're measuring only free
naloxone then that other portion of the
drug is invisible however if we were
measuring naloxone glucuronidation and
plasma during those pharmacokinetic
studies our theory is that we would
actually see that there is reasonably
high concentrations it's just not active
because once it has the glue Kieran I'd
added it's no longer going to act as an
antagonist as an opioid antagonist I
couldn't find any studies they may be
available showing that this had been
measured in plasma with during
pharmacokinetic studies of sublingual in
the lock tones there are some methods
out there so I think they've probably
been done but as far as I could tell
it's not been published of course once
the drug is being cleared really if
we're looking only for free naloxone and
urine and our work shows us there's very
low concentrations and the kitten what
we measured mostly less than five
nanograms per mil but if you're
measuring total naloxone by hydrolyzing
the glue carotid or if you measured
naloxone Gujarat I drew you would see
relatively high concentrations so that's
what we think is going on that's just
good to remember that absorption is not
the same thing as bioavailability there
is some supportive evidence for this
hypothesis one is that if you look at
naloxone peak exposure in patients with
severe hepatic impairment and a couple
of good studies have been done on this
you have much higher pre naloxone
concentrations over a thousand percent
higher so this is consistent with the
idea that you have a high rate of gluts
around a Dacian under normal
circumstances and when that's impaired
when you have paddock damage you have
higher free naloxone concentrations also
if you look at the concentrations that
are measured in pharmacokinetic studies
this is for pre naloxone with sublingual
buprenorphine naloxone that's an 8 to 8
milligram mix you see as expected very
low concentrations of free but in the
one study I could find where they
developed and validated a method for Ana
locks and good drive this is oral rather
than sublingual administration and
Attila Dean rather than buprenorphine
but it is in the last phone and actually
a lower dose of laudanum and they
measured over a hundred fold higher
concentrations when they are measuring
neurological glue tyranide so we feel
that that's consistent with our
hypothesis that the drug is absorbed it
just rapidly glitter on a date it in
therefore inactivated
this is just to remind me that we're
moving on to the next session and that
is talking a little bit about testing to
detect sample adulteration so what is
the ways to do that is to look at
absolute concentrations from a study in
which total buprenorphine was measured
and I've given you the reference there
down at the bottom
they found that a threshold of 700
nanograms per mil offered the best
accuracy for trying to discriminate
between an adulterated and ADAT
non adulterated specimen so this would
be that somebody say dips their
buprenorphine naloxone fill many Gurren
before handing the specimen over for
testing the second study is from dr.
Glen McMillan and Stephanie marrow dr.
Stephanie Marin at a RUP laboratories
they were testing Cree buprenorphine so
it's important to remember to
distinguish free from total and they
found that a threshold of a hundred data
grams per mil particularly when there
was lone or buprenorphine what suspect
as urine adulteration so one also needs
to look at the relative concentrations
of buprenorphine to Locke's own and
metabolites we'll look at that in a
minute and again it's important to
distinguish both in our reporting and
when we're talking about it whether we
mean free or total or glue Quran ID when
we're measuring these species so looking
at the ratios the ratio of free nor
buprenorphine to free buprenorphine was
reported for 786 samples by the group at
a RUP and that ratio was called the
metabolic ratio other people had coined
that term and done this reported these
ratios for total measurement of drug
this is for samples they divided their
cohort into those with a free
buprenorphine less than 100 nanograms
per mil and we saw that that metabolic
ratio than the mean was about 36 in the
median was 25 meaning is nor
buprenorphine was a lot higher than the
buprenorphine in the second cohort which
was a much smaller number of samples
with the free buprenorphine was greater
than 100 nanograms per mil they found
that that metabolic ratio was much lower
less than one with some several
subcategories there but indicating that
the much lower nor buprenorphine at
higher buprenorphine concentration so
again I want to point out this is free
not total analytes so this is showing
you the typical profile that you would
see in a sample this is one of our
samples tested at UCSD with free methods
so the free Nord buprenorphine is quite
high to 150 the buprenorphine is much
lower 6.8 and in this case we did detect
a little Freedman lock zone 6r as I said
before our cutoff is 5 so many of the
samples are less supply in contrast to
that would be an adulterated sample
we've only seen one that is this obvious
there we have very high super narking
concentrations around 800 the naloxone
is around 300 so this isn't quite afford
to one ratio but it's not so far off and
then only a tiny bit of noir
buprenorphine so this presumably comes
from a patient who had been taking their
drug and then missed several doses and
adulterated the specimen with some of a
buprenorphine naloxone preparation so
this really was emphasized for us when
we tested this particular sample with
both our free method and our total
method and what you can see is that we
get almost exactly the same result about
800 for the buprenorphine around 300 for
the naloxone and almost the same results
for the noir buprenorphine so this
essentially tells us that everything
that's present in that sample is free
there's essentially no glue Quran ID
all right so we have some background to
understand what's present in a urine
sample given that what are some common
cut-offs they're used for testing urine
samples for patients that are being
monitored for buprenorphine sublingual
therapy so I looked consulted colleagues
in the literature and looked at the web
pages for commercial reference labs and
the most common cut-offs are somewhere
between two and five nanograms per mil
for free or total buprenorphine and nor
buprenorphine or for the glue tyranide
there was one lab that used to cut off
two nanograms per mil for a total
naloxone and one that uses a cut-off of
it's 100 nanograms per mil for free
naloxone now there are methods in the
literature that have validated
quantitation limits that are much lower
in the picogram per mil range for
buprenorphine or buprenorphine and the
Glitter on eyes but to my knowledge
those are not used routinely for
monitoring samples of patients and
treatment most of the research that's
been reported for patient cohorts is
using those higher cut-offs that I
described all of these are using LC
tandem mass spec for testing so the
take-home message is that you can expect
that in compliant patients the nor
deepen or Fein is going to be higher
much higher than the buprenorphine the
ratio of those two may be helpful if
there's a question about compliance and
it's important to know whether that
ratio has been measured with total or
free methods
gudren eyes are also present in urine at
much higher concentrations than the free
drug and so again one needs to define
what's being measured and finally that
monitoring only free buprenorphine nor
buprenorphine in the LOC zone does not
seem to be in common use so let's go on
now and talk about the analytical
chemistry of that analysis this is all
using positive mode electrospray
ionisation LC tandem aspect so what are
the challenges of your current Dupin or
f---ing testing now that we have this
background well first of all that if you
measure with those cut-offs they've just
described as two to five nanograms per
mil if you're measuring only free drug
you're going to have false negative
so one solution to that is to measure
both the gluts rides themselves as well
as the free species and so that gives
you more inadequate information you're
not at the risk of a false negative but
it does mean that you have more
measurements so instead of three
substances for which you have to create
calibrators and quality control material
and review peak and measure track
quality control you have six so
definitely more work although it's also
more information so as we've described
the other solution would be to hydrolyze
the glue tyrannize and then measure
everything is free because you have much
higher concentrations which you've done
that however nor buprenorphine glue
Quran ID is notoriously resistant to
enzymatic hydrolysis compared to the
other opiates that we typically
hydrolyze and I've given you the classic
reference down there at the bottom from
dr. al Chile's lab describing those
issues typically taking much longer than
the other enzymatic protocols say from
morphine good for our mind and so I
would say as a result what it means is
that there's greater uncertainty
surrounding total nor marketing
concentrations between different
laboratories that use different
hydrolysis protocols we certainly found
that our protocol original protocol was
very vulnerable all to a low pH or high
pH in samples and we had to modify that
to have a stronger buffer concentration
a better control of pH so that we had
more consistent hydrolysis between a
range of patient sample furthermore if
you're interested in measuring the LOC
zone and the glue tyranide they're quite
polar the glue Quran I had most of all
of course and so they allude earlier in
a reverse phase LC and they ionize less
well than buprenorphine or Nord
buprenorphine so they're more
challenging to measure at low
concentration
however is that free only testing it
seems like it would be logistically
easier if we could avoid the enzyme
hydrolysis and we could measure only
three compounds and not six potentially
it would be easier testing potentially
better reproducibility and certainly
less expensive so the question is can we
come up with sufficiently low cut-offs
that free testing can be clinically
useful and so we decided to look at this
by testing all of the clinical samples
for patients and treatment that would be
submitted with both validated free and
total methods using cut-offs for the
free analytes of 0.2 0.5 is five
nanograms per mil as for the free beef
northing nor buprenorphine and alloxan
respectively and cutoff of 5 5 and 10
nanograms per mil for the total analyte
we also had some discussion with the
primary clinician who uses our service
for buprenorphine testing and she was
comfortable with the idea that we would
define a compliance sample is positive
for Nord beat for Northman so that would
be at a cut-off as 0.5 nanograms per mil
for free and a five nanograms per mil
for total and so even if the
buprenorphine was negative the patient
would sue be considered compliant so
long as there was a positive Nord
buprenorphine
so we were interested in using the TK
NAC plate for free buprenorphine testing
we were doing some collaboration with T
kin around developing and validating
methods using that extraction medium if
you're not familiar with it
there is a proprietary nonpolar resin
that's coated on the wealth of 9600
format plates I think that the easiest
way to think about how this extraction
works is that it's an immobilized liquid
liquid extraction so your analytes are
going to partition into that nonpolar
resin in the same manner that they would
partition into let's say an admissible
organic phase like hexane ethyl acetate
from your urine sample but logistically
it's much easier it's simple to automate
all you do is pipette and then put the
plates on an orbital shaker so you don't
have any floats or extraction medium
there's no centrifugation
there's no manual separation of a liquid
liquid layer
although you can after you loot from the
resin into the wells of the plate you
can evaporate that and reconstitute it
our goal was to have no evaporation and
reconstitution step so that we could
have a hundred percent of the sample
preparation being done on the deck
processed by the liquid handler so this
is the diagram that tkn puts out on how
this extraction works the first step is
to mix a sample with an internal
standard typical for any extraction
procedure for LCMS and add some
extraction buffer so that we have both
the analyte in the matrix in an
appropriate environment such that is
going to extract well into the resin and
that's done by ten minutes of mixing on
an orbital shaker then the pipette
pipette tips are used to throw away that
extraction waste and the next step would
be add a wash solution so that's to
remove residual matrix and again they're
shaking typically for five minutes then
the tips are used to throw away that
waste and finally an Aleutian reagent is
added so in some manner we shifted the
conditions the organic solvent or the pH
or both such that the gamma light comes
back out of the resin into the liquid
phase again for the five minutes of
shaking and then finally IT Ken
recommends that you transfer that to an
injection plate although you don't have
to so compared to other extraction
options the advantages are that it's
easy to automate we only have one liquid
handler so we actually do this protocol
we have a manual backup procedure you
just have to be very careful about
cross-contamination between wells it has
excellent reproducibility I made
mistakes while I was doing method
validation and it was quite forgiving
and finally it had good detection limits
for us there's a low recovery as you'll
see in a few slides but there's a
proportionately greater decrease in
noise and we're able to successfully get
rid of matrix so you end up with an
excellent signal-to-noise of course
there's always some disadvantages there
is less concentration that's possible if
you're using a flow through media where
anybody who does solid phase extraction
knows you can put a very large volume
through an SP cartridge or play
whereas in this case you're limited to a
total volume and the well of three
hundred microliters and that has to
include your internal standard and your
extraction buffer perhaps the biggest
limitation in terms of the menu of
compounds that we can be tested with
this technique is that it's applicable
to nonpolar analytes so they have to
have a log P or log D which is the pH
sensitive log P that's greater than 3 in
order to be extracted
so let's take another look at our
analyte chemistry and you can see that
we have these phenolic groups on all
three of our analytes that at a high pH
can become ionized and therefore make
the molecule more polar more importantly
is the amino group that all of them have
and a low pH that can become protonated
and charged and again affect the
polarity so we have to pay attention to
both of these things when we're thinking
about how we want to get this molecule
and its most nonpolar States so that we
can extract it so if we look at the log
piece for these three compounds you can
see that buprenorphine as a log p of
almost 5 nor buprenorphine is three
point six but naloxone is below that
threshold that I mentioned earlier of
three it's only one point nine if you're
not familiar with a log P it's just the
number that's derived traditionally by
putting a compound in aqueous and mixing
it was optional and then measuring how
it partitions and taking the log value
of that so obviously from buprenorphine
and a lot so and we're talking about
less to more polar but what's
interesting is the pH if you like
lability of the polarity for this group
of compounds so as I mentioned earlier
the amino group when it's protonated has
a major effect on the polarity so we've
got a tenfold decrease it's much more
polar for buprenorphine from four point
nine eight zero point four five
in contrast to that the phenolic group
has much less of effect on polarity but
I've given you the pka's for all three
of those compounds both for the amine
and for the phenol and I just want to
point out that it's important to
remember that log P these days is more
often calculated than it is measured and
so depending on which software is use
you're going to see quite different
values for log p depending on which
source you consult so the fact that
there were those two pka's that
potentially there might be an optimal pH
where our molecules of interest were at
their most non-polar States
led me to think about this so here the
axis is pH and what is the corresponding
log D so at low pH is acidic we have a
charge on the main group at high pH
basic we have a charge on the phenol
group is there something in the middle
where we either have no charge or we
have a submitter eye on what pH would
that be and what is the resulting log D
that was our question so I felt quite
proud of myself that I'd consulted the
older medical literature back in the 60s
and 70s about this but if so often
happened somebody else had thought of it
before
so in preparation for this webinar I
came across this reference from 1997 and
Everhart Henry group had published a
method for subs nanogram concentration
measurement of buprenorphine and
metabolites this was using because
before lc/ms was in why do so is using
gas chromatography but they also
identified pH 9.1 beza
optimal pH so we looked at how well
these compounds extracted this was just
in an aqueous low organic mixture at a
pH of 6 7 8 9 and 10 and then looked at
the raw peak area these are measurements
in triplicate and what you can see is
that Norview preneur gain is drastically
affected by the pH sorry naloxone is
drastically affected by the pH in terms
of the extraction efficiency nor
buprenorphine only a little bit here in
the red and the buprenorphine not very
much at all and so the optimal pH that
we define for extraction was 9.1 same
thing as the earlier authors
our extraction workflow using a tiki and
freedom evil 100 liquid handler and the
AC plate C liquid has 150 micro liters
of urine to a well the AC plate at 25
microliters of internal standard working
internal standard to deuterated an
internal standard for all three
compounds mixes for two minutes then we
add 125 microliters of a very strong
ionic strength sodium bicarbonate buffer
at pH 9.1 it's shaken on the orbital
mixer for 10 minutes to extract waste is
discarded and then there's a wash step
maintaining a safe pH but a little bit
with a little bit of methanol to remove
some matrix and then finally after the
waste is discarded an illusion step
where we have 20% Osito nitrile in water
but the important component here is the
formic acid which shifts the pH to less
than 2 the compounds all become
protonated and then partition ala to the
resin back into the liquid phase we
transfer it to an injection plate and
eject 7 Mike leaders on the lc-ms so
I've given you the method parameters
here both for the hydrolysis and for the
lcms I'm not going to spend any time on
this if you're interested leverets can
provide you with a PDF handout as a
presentation and you're also welcome
we're happy to share our SOP with
anybody who'd be interested in
implementing the method just send them
an email and we'll be able to provide
you with the SOP so of course one of the
things we always worry about with lcms
is matrix effectiveness just showing you
graphically experiment of post column
infusion to evaluate this is the sixth
gradient that I looked at we tried it
three minute LC run but we had too much
matrix effect so we had to lengthen that
to four minutes here you can see four in
the lock zone these big negative
deflections are showing us where we've
lost signal due to Co eluding matrix but
we're free of that with this gradient at
the time that naloxone a loose
for Noor buprenorphine this is a for the
total extraction procedure you can see
that it also looks good we have big
negative deflections but they're on
either side of our retention time for
Noor buprenorphine and for buprenorphine
you can see it's pretty edgy isn't it
there's this big negative deflection
that we see for all samples and the
retention time for buprenorphine is just
after that so we expected that we might
have problems with that
but in fact this is showing you the same
data a slightly different manner this is
for the free process again you can see
that naloxone is alluding away from ion
suppression nor buprenorphine appears to
be of those a little something here
isn't there I'll come back to that
and finally buprenorphine is once again
right on the edge of a major array of
eye expression however what we found is
in production we don't really have
problems with this and the samples that
we encounter routinely whereas
unfortunately with Noor buprenorphine we
do have the occasional sample that has
severe eye and suppression and so we
have to dilute that times 10 so the
drug-free urine and that for the most
part gets rid of the eye in suppression
but it is an extra step and so probably
the LC program could be improved to
separate Noor buprenorphine from this
area of iron suppression we just haven't
bothered to do that so far we also do
quantitative matrix effect studies and
we had good hydrolysis recovery with low
variance if we look at the extraction
recovery as I mentioned very low indeed
for naloxone and particularly only 7%
and the highest was for buprenorphine at
42% however we have good precision
slightly higher than the threshold
that's published by the College of
American Pathologists where they say
they should be less a 15% or less
variance between samples but you'll see
in the next table that that is corrected
with the internal standard and the same
thing for matrix effect we have low
variance between samples this is spiking
the drug at these two different
concentrations into ten different
patient samples
a little more iron suppression for
buprenorphine that we'd like to see but
as you can see when we ratio the
recovery of the analyte to the ratio of
the deuterated internal standard that's
corrected completely and we have better
precision and it's the same story for
matrix effect so ultimately when it
would combine those two things as those
of you who do these studies routinely
are familiar with for what we call the
process efficiency we have good numbers
values around 100 and with precision
less than 10% between samples so as a
chromatographer we always have to show
you peak this is a naloxone nor
buprenorphine and buprenorphine this is
the quantitative mrm trace at the lower
limit of quantitation so this is the
cutoff you can see that the peak shape
is not ideal for a naloxone or nor
buprenorphine it's much better for
buprenorphine which has a much greater
response for the same concentration but
these were adequate they all had a
signal-to-noise greater than 10 naloxone
has the lowest signal they all pest iron
ratios within plus or minus 20% and they
all had at least 11 to 12 scale to read
the absolute min of them that you
minimum that you'd like to see for
quantitation so how precise is this
protocol at such low concentrations and
with kind of barely acceptable peak
shape well actually it was reasonably
good this is a validation study for the
free method we tested a pool at four
nanograms for naloxone for nanograms per
ml for naloxone and 0.4 for nor
buprenorphine and buprenorphine had all
had CVS less than 15% and then for these
two higher concentrations cv is less
than as you can see five and seven
percent of course it's always easy to be
precise during validation the question
is how well does the method work in
production and here's our numbers for
the production QC from last November
until this August and you can see that
for our low and high control at these
concentrations higher for naloxone and
around 1.5 nano grams per mil and
seventy five nanograms per mil for free
buprenorphine and noir different are
painted our CVS are accessible less than
eight percent less than five percent
so let's get back to our original
question what results did we get when we
tested all 214 samples that come from
patients who are in treatment with the
free and total methods and basically the
two techniques agreed remember we have
different cut-offs of course we have to
have much lower cut-offs with the free
method and so we divided those into two
categories so the one which was 92% of
the samples we had all the results agree
87 percent of the samples different
working in Nordica narking were positive
as both methods for only 3% did we
actually have negative with both methods
and then we had small number of samples
only three where the nor buprenorphine
was positive and the buprenorphine was
negative with both methods we had this
other set of samples with an or
different or fiend results agree and
remember that's the criteria that we're
using to evaluate a specimen as being
from a compliant patient but there was
disagreement for the buprenorphine and
most of those were the case where the
total method was positive for
buprenorphine in the free method was
negative there was a small segment in
the other category so this is just a
graph showing you a plot of those
results this is total naloxone on this
axis and you'll see that concentrations
go up as high as almost 6,000 nanograms
from milk and this is the percent free
for each of those samples and you can
see that the yield is actually very low
less than 2% free and and most of that
is that it's a lot most of these
specimens that concentration was below
the detection limit less than 5 so if we
look at the same thought for a total nor
buprenorphine versus percent free you
can see that we have a higher percent
free around 20 to 30 percent and that's
what saves us essentially and allows us
to use a cut-off of 0.5 nanograms per
mil for the free method and you can see
again concentrations go as high as 4,000
nanograms per mil for the total and
finally for buprenorphine the same plot
this is we saw a percentage somewhere
between 2 and 5 percent free for most of
the samples that were measured for total
and previous northing and in both of
these plots were the 1 for nor
buprenorphine started one for naloxone
and the one for buprenorphine I have
omitted that one sample that I showed
you earlier and that was because there
was essentially a hundred percent of
free buprenorphine and a hundred percent
of free naloxone and so it would
completely
would bias the plot seriously if I
included it so inclusion conclusion we
feel that free buprenorphine measured at
a cut-off of 0.5 nanograms per mil can
be used for monitoring compliance with
buprenorphine therapy the extraction is
relatively simple and easy to automate
we would like to see studies at other
centers to see if they have the same
result and timing we still do offer the
total buprenorphine in the tablet method
on request but we no longer do it by
reflex if we we've had a few samples
since we changed our policy that were
negative
completely with the free method we
actually ended up repeating them and
doing the total just to reassure
ourselves and they were all congruent so
that concludes my presentation I thank
you for your time happy to answer
questions
Thank You dr. stone for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on the answer question box
located on the far left to your screen
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is do you recommend
that free blueprint or f---ing testing
replace testing with total Bluford or
f---ing or testing for FLE free excuse
me for free glue cure Knights I I don't
actually I think that any one of these
methods whether it's free only whether
it's the total protocol that I would say
it's probably most commonly used at
reference labs as well as academic
medical centers that do necessity or the
perhaps when it provides the most
information the free plus glue tirana
testing beginning one of those can give
answers it's what's most appropriate at
your site there's such a burden for
doing method validation and development
I don't know that that many sites would
want to replace their current protocol
but if you're new to this type of
testing I would encourage you to think
about whether this might be suitable for
you it may require some additional
consultation with your clinicians so
that they understand if they've been
getting testing save a total and now
you're switching to free but that's
always a productive conversation to have
anyway regardless of what methods you'll
be testing with so I just really sounds
a little pretentious the title of a new
paradigm I really what I probably should
have said is a new option it's another
way that the testing can be done and I'm
happy to say that now when we first
talked about presenting this we didn't
have much experience with it we was
doing it for about six months now live
and we've had good success with it
and it looks like our next question is
how well have the clinicians in your
health system accepted this approach
this approach to purpose buprenorphine
monitoring so it was a pleasant surprise
for us and I think it just speaks to the
excellence and the knowledge of
clinicians that we're dealing with
primarily one specialist in substance
abuse treatment that she is very open to
looking at a different way of testing
and we get in touch whenever we have a
sample that's completely negative and
asked if we should retest her should we
do the total testing and depending on
the circumstances some ways times we do
one and sometimes do the other but it
was a really positive experience for us
and I would encourage you you know to
reach out if you're knowledgeable about
the topic not just about of course the
testing for it but how it's being used
by clinicians I think that people will
be open and particularly if it means
that you can get results with a faster
turnaround time or there's easier
communication let's say with the
laboratory within your health system
versus sending it out I think there's
definitely advantages
now dr. stone do you have any problems
with matrix effect in the samples
encountered with routine production
testing yeah so as I mentioned
unfortunately we do see a some severe
negative depression of the internal
standard therefore reflecting also
depression of the analyte signal for
preen or buprenorphine we we don't see
that with a naloxone or with different
our veins and as I said our solution
which we validated has been successful
by diluting it luckily these samples are
positive and they're quite positive so
our quantitation is fairly similar in
those samples that we dilute and then do
not see the matrix effect but we still
are performing the dilution as I said I
think the long-term solution really
would be to modify the LC gradient such
that we move the noir paper nation away
from that region of ion suppression that
we see is I would say just a few samples
it may well be that those patients are
all taking the same drug we really
haven't done the homework yet to say
whether that's the case or not but yes
we have encountered semi ins freshen
problem so we are getting so many good
questions today but it looks like we
only have time for one more
so dr. stone what do you use for
collaborators and QC material so we make
our own calibrators in drug-free urine
and we have purchased commercial PC when
we were doing the total protocol we
purchased it with noir buprenorphine
glue Quran ID for an orphan blue karate
and naloxone will appear on ID in it so
that we could to see our hydrolysis
process but now that our primary testing
mode is just free we're purchasing it
with the free drug present and that's
worked well for us we feel strongly that
we don't like to make up both the QC and
the calibrators ourselves if we make up
one we'd like to purchase the other
commercially so that we have a check on
our accuracy
dr. stone do you have any final comments
for our audience I don't think so I
think that I hope that this presentation
has be useful it's been useful to you
and again anybody is interested in doing
this type of testing we're happy to
share our SOP which is is anybody who
knows me incredibly detailed and so
potentially could allow you to get
started with the testing just get in
touch with lab routes and they'll act to
connect us so that I can give you a copy
of it thanks again for the opportunity
to talk to you today before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
just a reminder any questions we did not
have time for today will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of the
registration we would like to thank
laborat and our educational sponsor
agilent for today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through March of 2019 labret will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's by the vit until next
time goodbye